on this tuesday night the rcmp's top cop
on the record
commissioner brenda lucky in her own
words at the nova scotia massacre
inquiry things were not flowing the way
they ought to have the response from
some of the victims families
healthcare staff crunch we don't have
the bodies to fill the positions the
cost of bringing in temps soars to
staggering new levels
canada's hefty hydrogen deal with
germany and how not all of this fuel is
created equal
plus the world-renowned canadian
architect raising the roof
time has finally come with his
monumental donation to mcgill university
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us the head of the rcmp took the witness
stand today to begin her highly
anticipated testimony at the inquiry
that's examining the 2020 nova scotia
mass shooting brenda lucky faced many
questions but allegations of political
interference dominated the conversation
questions surrounding whether or not she
applied pressure to release information
about the gunman's firearms
it was a question it wasn't
are the guns going to be mentioned in
the media race it wasn't it wasn't
bigger than what
what
everybody is making it out to it's it's
becoming very politicized this whole
event as far as i'm concerned because it
was not
nearly as big as you're making it sound
commissioner lucky also faced questions
about rcmp communications internal
reviews and the force's response to the
massacre callum smith has our top story
tonight
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
thank you rcmp commissioner brenda lucky
repeating her denials about political
interference about releasing the types
of weapons used multiple senior rcmp
officials in nova scotia have alleged
that pressure tuesday she denied it
again there was never any direction
provided no interference no political
pressure was there pressure yeah there
was a lot of pressure most of it coming
from the media itself but as far as
what people think happened it didn't
lucky describing tuesday how many
external reviews and recommendations are
publicly shared since i got in the chair
one of the things that we've really been
focusing on is transparency and
accountability this is the inquiry
learns more about a handful of internal
rcmp reviews about the april 2020
killings in nova scotia that may have
started but none completed a variety of
reasons heard by nova scotia's
commanding officer at the time lee
bergerman including this inquiry lengthy
investigations and capacity lucky said
ottawa had capacity to support that she
also said ideally communications
personnel from ottawa could have been on
the ground helping in nova scotia but
that coveted concerns prevented that
things were not flowing the way they
ought to have
and it wasn't meeting my expectations so
i wanted to have that conversation
the force's communication has been under
scrutiny due to conflicting information
in part between the commissioner and
nova scotia rcmp including the number of
fatalities in early hours there wasn't
much new information tuesday lucky
saying she doesn't have much intimate
detail about on-the-ground information
but she agreed accurate and timely
information is key but for scott macleod
who lost his brother sean trust in the
inquiry is waning not real high anymore
i come in here with hopes of
information coming out and things being
looked at you know
fixing wrongdoing from my client's
perspective really curious and
interested in
pressing the commissioner on how change
is actually implemented
cross-examination continues wednesday
callum smith global news halifax
and an update on a story we brought you
last week the prime minister says it's
unacceptable that a canadian forces
veteran seeking treatment for
post-traumatic stress disorder and a
traumatic brain injury was casually
offered medical assistance in dying by a
veterans affairs canada employee the
veterans affairs service agent brought
up the issue unprompted in a
conversation with the veteran
it's absolutely unacceptable
that
this veteran would have been
suggested or offered medical assistance
and dying that is not
the duty of care that we have towards
veterans
veterans affairs canada is not allowed
to offer resources for medically
assisted death to soldiers to healthcare
now over the last two and a half years
frontline workers have been leaving the
sector in droves aging staff and burnout
are among the reasons behind a resource
crisis that's led to a huge backlog in
care over the next few weeks global news
is going to take a deep look at the
state of health care in this country and
not just the issues facing our emergency
rooms but ways to fix them according to
those who work in the field we're
calling the series code blue tonight in
part one jamie morocco looks at the
impact on both small towns and major
city centers
when a recent case of covid left bernie
woods struggling to breathe she called
for help and while an ambulance was
there quickly the weight to see a doctor
would be anything but i was told well
the weight is going to be 16 to 20 hours
or longer and i'm like oh my god lengthy
or even outrageous wait times aren't out
of the ordinary at charlottetown's
largest hospital in rural pei the strain
has translated to closures of urgent
care centers for days or even weeks our
issue with this has entirely been
related to staffing the problem is real
all across canada in ashcroft bc its
continuous emergency room closures have
become deadly for residents there the
closest hospital is about an hour away
in kamloops and outside ottawa the main
hospital in perth ontario has drawn
scrutiny for its numerous shutdowns
hospital ceo michael cohen says although
the doors are back open staffing there
is still slim the number one challenge
is just we don't have the bodies to fill
the positions so agency or outside
temporary nursing staff has become the
pricey stop gap cohen worries the cost
isn't feasible for very much longer
we're very concerned about the fall but
the reality is that agency staffing is
not a permanent solution even big city
bottom lines are feeling the budget
pressures at canada's largest research
hospital in toronto costs from sourcing
new staff have skyrocketed we've
normally seen about 750 000 to 1.1
million dollars
annually in agency costs
in the last year that's about seven
million dollars that's an increase of
more than 500 percent and while unit
closures aren't as common in major city
centers there is concern the mass worker
exodus on the front lines is putting
even more pressure on those who remain
while also eroding patient care and
critically trust
sometimes when there are there is some
personnel missing it can be up to six
patients for one nurse
that's very worrisome because this is a
specialized care hospital at 63 bernie
wood is worried about aging inside such
a strained system it's going to get
worse and worse
unsure about the quality of care she can
expect
the next time she needs it
jamie morocco global news toronto
one move that could help improve the
quality of health care canada's new
chief nursing officer was named today
for the first time since the position
was quietly eliminated by the
conservatives in 2012. the federal
government has appointed lee chapman to
the advisory role the registered nurse
has nearly 20 years of leadership
experience including work in critical
care and harm reduction
i have a deep commitment to health
equity
and building a health care system
reflective of all canadians especially
marginalized and vulnerable populations
the appointment is for two years and it
could be extended while the war in
ukraine continues to loom over all their
discussions a second day of meetings
between the prime minister and the
german chancellor were focused on
forging stronger ties between the two
nations and the transition to green
energy this as pressure builds on canada
to help europe cut its dependence on
russian gas our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson traveled with the two
leaders to newfoundland and labrador and
joins us now mercedes
it's a beautiful summer day here in
stephenville newfoundland and labrador
and most canadians aren't thinking about
winter but for european leaders who are
facing a dire fossil fuel shortage
heading into the colder months they are
out looking for fuel supplies for their
people to keep the lights on and the
trains running quite literally vladimir
putin's weaponization of fossil fuels
has brought german chancellor olaf
schultz here to canada to tour with
prime minister justin trudeau in search
of a far less established fuel source
hydrogen the production of which would
be driven by the relentless winds here
on newfoundland and labrador's coast
hydrogen would provide a clean energy
source one that germany wants to import
and trudeau believes canada is naturally
positioned to be a powerhouse for canada
has what it takes to be a supplier
of clean energy in a net zero world you
might think an energy deal would be
better suited for alberta's oil sands
but that would be off-brand for two
politicians struggling to balance their
environmental platforms with pressing
energy demands despite alberta's wealth
of natural gas there is no
infrastructure on canada's east coast to
ship it to europe and senior government
sources say there's not much political
will to build it either
canada could ship more natural gas to
the u.s but that's not top of mind for
the trudeau cabinet the project
announced today signals the direction of
the government as does the agreement for
canada to produce hydrogen to ship to
germany across the atlantic but much of
it is uncertain even the permits for
this project have not yet been approved
and the agreement is non-binding project
here in stephenville won't be ready to
ship hydrogen until at least 2025 and
even senior officials in the prime
minister's office say that is ambitious
because there's so much infrastructure
that has to be built both to make that
hydrogen and to be able to ship it in
that transatlantic corridor to countries
like germany pharaoh
mercedes stevenson in stephenville
newfoundland and labrador thanks
mercedes there have been significant
investments in hydrogen production in
some parts of canada but not all
hydrogen is equal at least in the eyes
of world markets hydrogen is the most
abundant element in the universe and it
holds the promises of becoming a
limitless green fuel as heather urux
west reports for many would-be customers
the question of which process is used to
actually extract it is going to play an
important role in choosing suppliers
with global temperatures and fuel costs
rising the global need for cheap and
clean energy sources is unlike anything
before clean burning hydrogen might just
be the fix the world is looking for and
canada is ready to deal we're beginning
to see the hydrogen economy uh instead
of variety of pilot programs which are
really very exciting a lot of it
centered in the edmonton industrial
region considered a clean fuel because
when it burns hydrogen leaves only water
behind but the fuel can have a carbon
footprint depending on how it's produced
it's carbon intensity coated in a system
of nine colors green is the cleanest
produced using renewable energy like
wind power
gray brown and black hydrogen are the
worst hydrogen made from fossil fuels
most hydrogen products being explored
and invested in alberta are coated blue
still produced by fossil fuels like
natural gas but relying on carbon
capture and storage systems european
markets want green hydrogen but those
projects don't come cheap green hydrogen
is far from being cost competitive but
of course with electricity rates at the
level that they're at in europe a lot of
things start to look more attractive in
comparison we just have to be
realistic about
our like the capacity of
these new technologies so lng canada
produces around 330 times more energy
than this
green energy gh2 facility
can export it's why this deal isn't
expected to turn the tide of europe's
energy crisis still environmental groups
say germany is right to demand nothing
less than a hydrogen completely green
the climate impacts of using natural gas
to make hydrogen
are tremendous
it is a huge carbon bond that's not to
say there isn't interest in exporting
canada's blue hydrogen elsewhere with
asian markets looking to bring this fuel
source their way heather urex west
global news calgary
threats lingering in the air coming up
how ukraine says it will respond to new
attacks from russia
competitive soccer returned to war-torn
ukraine today there were no fans in the
stands as players took to the fields for
the first time since the russian
invasion the opening coincides with
ukraine's national flag day a show of
defiance against the war the premier
league season will be played under heavy
security in stadiums far from the front
lines
but tonight there are new warnings
russia could intensify its attacks to
coincide with ukraine's independence day
the u.s state department has told its
citizens to leave ukraine now as redmond
shannon reports president vlodimir
zielinski says his country will have a
powerful response to any russian
escalation
flag day in ukraine on the eve of
independence day but celebrations in
kiev are banned wednesday amid high
alert of a russian attack on a day that
also marks six months of war
the second city of harkeev is on a
36-hour lockdown
following warnings from president
vladimir zelinsky the united states has
advised its citizens to leave ukraine as
soon as possible
zielinski said any russian attack will
receive a powerful response
talk of revenge in russia too at the
memorial for nationalist tv commentator
daria dugina ukraine denies russian
claims it was behind the car bomb that
killed her on saturday
her father far-right ideologue alexander
dugan says she died in the name of
russian truth and
russian victory
at an international diplomatic
conference in kiev zielinski told world
leaders that his country's victory must
include taking back crimea annexed by
russia eight years ago we can't forget
that putin's invasion of ukraine really
started in 2014. we should have the
humility to acknowledge that not
everybody realized the sheer enormity of
what was happening at the time the west
may have regrets about crimea but it
can't afford regrets about zaparisia the
head of the international atomic energy
agency says he expects a mission to
finally be allowed to visit the
russian-controlled nuclear power plant
within days
both sides in the war blame the other
for the ongoing shelling being reported
there risking catastrophe at europe's
largest nuclear plant the city beside it
is named ener hodar energy's gift
of course we are worried how can it not
worry us says this man
it's like sitting on a powder keg
redmond shannon global news london
all dried up ahead the stark toll of
drought conditions plaguing earth's
northern
hemisphere over the past few months
we've shared stark images like these
highlighting the severity of droughts
and water shortages impacting much of
the northern hemisphere water bodies
like lakes rivers and canals are rapidly
receding or worse drying up creating
water shortages as eric sorensen reports
while the immediate conditions are
causing worry in many countries the
future impact is alarming
in china there's been so little rain
that a 600 year old statue of buddha has
been uncovered on a dried-up stretch of
the yangtze river satellite pictures
show chinese rivers full in april and
parched in august
news broadcasts show fire trucks
delivering emergency water everywhere
crops are withering
china's drought is remarkable but what's
extraordinary is how many intense dry
spells are happening around the world
the worst conditions are in east africa
the u.n says as many as 22 million
people could face extreme hunger in the
months ahead
there was no rain he says whatever we
planted did not grow one factor is the
la nina current persisting for a third
year in the eastern pacific it
contributes to dry conditions as far
away as the horn of africa but also
across the pacific from chile to mexico
to the southwestern u.s all enduring
exceptionally dry weather it's a cause
of concern because of all the
climate impacts that la nina has in the
form of drought climate change is
amplifying the impacts of these la ninas
even though it may not be having a
direct impact on
the occurrence of la nina itself while
canada has been relatively spared this
summer drought is scorching much of the
northern hemisphere virtually no
european country has escaped extreme and
persistent dry conditions
rivers all over western europe have
dropped to record low levels
in serbia scuttled german ships from the
second world war have been uncovered
while in england several kilometers of
the thames river is bone dry drinking
water for some is being delivered if you
don't have running water it makes you
question all the most basic sort of
complexities of life but in eastern
africa any water would be welcome
conflict on top of drought has made the
situation dire the driest season that we
have seen
in decades four or five rainy seasons
have just disappeared the world food
program says in this part of the world
people cannot wait for the weather to
change facing starvation they need food
and water now
eric sorensen global news toronto
next the world renowned architect
gifting his modern wonders to the next
generation
one of the world's most celebrated
architects moshe safdi is the mind
behind some of the most compelling
structures of the modern era and now
he's giving back to his canadian alma
mater in a big way donating his
extensive professional archive to mcgill
university and as dan spector explains
that includes a key piece of one of
montreal's most fascinating buildings
it's not every day a piece of
architecture stops you in your tracks
leaving you in awe wondering how someone
could possibly imagine it but that is
the power of renowned israeli-canadian
architect moshe safti and so many of his
designs including the jewel at
singapore's chaney airport an architect
is serving society and building for
society society as a whole
inclusively not selectively safti's
iconic works are spread out across the
globe and this country the 84 year old
is responsible for the national gallery
in ottawa toronto pearson airports
terminal 1 vancouver's public library
square and the habitat 67 housing
complex in montreal which actually began
as safety's undergraduate thesis at
mcgill university where he graduated
from the architecture school in 1961.
i'd say habitat is my firstborn and
maybe my most radical project now in a
grand gesture to give back to his alma
mater and the country that embraced him
safdi has donated his professional
archive to mcgill comprised of more than
100 thousand pieces it includes sketches
books models drawings
i felt mcgill where i studied where i
became an architect in canada that has
supported my work and supported me
and and
puts its confidence in me when i was a
young man is the right place to do it
the flagship piece safety's personal
apartment at habitat 67 which becomes a
hub for research exhibitions and more
for us as students what's interesting is
seeing the building the process that
actually went into it like how was it
put together learning about architecture
is about experiencing buildings you
can't just look at photographs you can't
just look at drawings you have to go and
be there safdi's goal with the
innovative building was to bring green
space and fresh air to the urban
environment an idea he since applied
around the world
i think the whole idea of sustainability
and climate change i think we're
beginning to understand that as we get
urbanized we better not forget how to
humanize a collection safdi hopes will
inspire students and the general public
for generations to come dan specter
global news montreal
what a gift to future architects and
that's global national for tuesday night
i'm farin asser on behalf of our whole
crew i want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is birds hill
provincial park near winnipeg until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other good night
[Music]
you